remember when a Starbucks cup showed up
in Westeros that's nothing compared to
this goop in The Last of Us better check
it out now before HBO scrubs it from the
show The Last of Us has maintained its
high quality throughout season one with
each episode scoring at least 94 on
Rotten Tomatoes and multiple critics
deeming the series emmy-worthy
viewership has also been high the show
essentially outpaced House of the Dragon
in streaming numbers when it premiered
meanwhile Bella Ramsay and Pedro Pascal
have become beloved internet stars but
that doesn't mean the series is perfect
despite the beautiful wide shots
throwing character development at heart
pounding action The Last of Us is
apparently capable of slipping up
sometimes can the sixth episode of The
Last of Us season one features some
spectacular scenery as Ellie and Joel
travel through a wintry Wonderland to a
firefly Outpost the camera drifts across
long expanses of untouched snowy Hills
and massive craggy mountain ranges and
vans certainly noticed the excellent
cinematography with one Twitter user
even saying that the episode's shots
were among the best on television but
the internet will always be around to
scour beloved properties for mistakes
is this really all they had to worry
about
boys movies one fan took to Twitter to
point out a flaw in one of those
beautiful line shots apparently some
crew members of The Last of Us can be
seen in the far bottom left of one of
the episodes striking overhead shots
it's a tiny error but of course on a
show like The Last of Us nothing is Tiny
this momentous occasion may even be the
Starbucks cup moment of this otherwise
spotless show for those who may not
remember HBO's Starbucks cup moment
occurred during the highly controversial
eighth season of Game of Thrones during
a celebratory scene at Winterfell a
modern looking coffee cup was plainly
seen on the table in front of Daenerys
of course that Starbucks moment was
heralded as another indication that Game
of Thrones had jumped the shark whereas
The Last of Us era is more of a
minuscule misstep in an otherwise great
series the good news is that other shows
competing for Emmys can now breathe easy
knowing that the last of us can
sometimes do wrong funny errors in big
budget Productions are nothing new in
addition to the Game of Thrones coffee
cup the Mandalorian had its own goof in
season 2 episode 4 when in the
background of an action sequence you
were could see a person wearing jeans
trying to hide apparently they didn't
get far enough out of the way of the
camera and they made their way into the
episode and into Star Wars lore of
course it wasn't long until Jean's guy
was taken out of the episode if you go
to Disney plus now to try to catch them
you'll be sorely disappointed that's
also what happened with the Game of
Thrones cup which fun fact actually
isn't from Starbucks despite the fact
that company apparently got somewhere in
the neighborhood of 2.3 billion dollars
in free advertising online from the gaff
as such it probably won't be long until
HBO catches wise and removes a crew from
the shot in question from The Last of Us
thanks to streaming platforms and
digital releases many projects appear to
be continual Works in progress Disney
patched some CGI for scene and Thor love
and thunder when the movie went up on
Disney plus who needs to get it right
the first time when you can fix it and
post or in this case post-post
foreign